for me success is about the impact you
make and what kind of legacy that you
leave behind say how many people use
what do what you've created what the
benefit is overall run in just financial
success I feel really it's more about
making a difference in people's lives
and to the world as a whole I'm managing
partner of collegiate capsule which is a
venture capital fund and company pole
builder where parts VC parts startup and
more than just writing checks our goal
is really to help startups on every
stage and journey so where there's
technical support legal support
accounting international expansion
hollering aid corporates etc say
actually really adding extra value
beyond just a few meetings and a check
which is a problem I feel with a lot of
the venture capital industry at the
moment so my first company is 16 since
then I've been doing most of stuff and
creating my own companies getting work
experience working in finance while
ending on finish at full-time after
graduating straightaway and to actually
join blackboard and get the experience
and then run my companies on the side so
I have the transient ice and banking and
to something I chose after management
because in terms of hours market hours
it gives you the freedom once you've
left the office to actually do things in
the evening at the same time you get the
experience you get that credibility as
well from working logic um you get that
trainers game and a lot of people think
oh this would be my own boss and do from
the start but actually do learn a lot
working for other people and especially
a large company that's become
established makes you more humble in one
in more than one element and then also
it helps you get an understanding of how
a large companies work because if you're
just a career entrepreneur and there's
nothing wrong with that but if it's only
used to kind of being the boss and
working for yourself and working small
teams when it gets to that stage really
willing to scale I feel that a lot of
founders do fall down then you have
cases where the original founders are
replaced by outside CEOs
outside channels etc because they're not
ready to run a company of that size they
don't have the skill set to to take it
from a small group of people to a much
much larger organization the next five
years we're hoping to really make a big
impact in the venture capital industry
work with when the exciting companies
and help grow them to the stage where
they can either exit at red cell or go
to IPO that's a dream and we're looking
to really help create the next
game-changing innovative companies in
the technology space particularly out of
Europe that's one particular after about
technology
catching up with the with it a whole
popular should see in the US and Silicon
Valley
and that's one thing I'm really hoping
to see you next big DNA codes coming out
of Europe